rich eisen in fact is in indianapolis
and the reason he's there of course is
to work for nfl network around the
the nfl combine but
there was something else in the mix uh a
mike mcdaniel
rich eisen
conspiracy maybe what could you call it
conspiracy well they were working
together to try something out yeah
coaches use cliches but rich has never
seen the holy trinity ever happen in one
press conference where three have been
used
this happened a little while ago
and here's how it went down
let's not forget like
it is what it is
you know i i i honestly was underrated
me personally i don't have a crystal
ball
you know
but we're really the only guys i can
talk about
are the players that are here today yes
excuse me pardon me
oh hey didn't see it boom
boy
triple play
[Applause]
that was amazing all right joining us
today now live from indianapolis on the
mercedes-benz vans
phone line is the host of this show and
apparently comedian extraordinaire rich
eisen rich how we doing well gents uh
i'm basking in the glow
i'm celebrating by
um soaking in the adoration of the crowd
by sitting on a parking bench around the
corner from the home of the pacers
sitting here by myself on an empty
street at two o'clock in the afternoon
like a total weirdo
send us a picture other than that
guys you know i've been chasing that
white whale for a while yeah and it's
finally done i brockman as i told you
you have to help me out after the red
sox won you kind of had no more purpose
on that front
where do we go from here guys that's
basically what says where do we go from
here well rich the next move obviously
is to get you on the competition
committee
that's true we just have to take it one
day at a time i don't have a crystal
ball i don't know what the future's
gonna hold for you uh i can only control
what i can control uh hopefully the best
because obviously it is what it is
i know what's his i know what his future
is he he he he's hit the he's hit the
pinnacle right there's nothing there's
nothing more to achieve here just hand
the baton you got a guy right here
rich his hand the baton i got i'll take
it from here hey
quick question
what was the question asked mike
mcdaniel in that moment that ultimately
got him to use your cliches
here's the way it went down guys uh he
came out
um and um answered questions seriously
and a couple of times had opportunities
to go in that direction it didn't
at one point
um he talked about
i guess somebody asked about mike
gosicki signing in free agency as you
know he's one of the top
free agents available if not certainly
at the position of tight end had a total
opportunity there to say he didn't have
a crystal ball
didn't
um
talked at one point about something
being what it is um and i'm like oh
especially when at one point
he talked about um
you know needing to have a certain
foundation
and how you know if things don't go a
certain way that's the way that you wind
up losing your hair and i thought like
that was
a shot in my direction
you know certainly since i thought it
was all about me today
um
and then the last question was asked of
him about xavier howard and how he's
going to come back to the team and
what's the plan and all of that
and before that question was asked at
the pr
person for the dolphins who was there
she says last question everybody i got
to be honest with you got nervous
thought that he might have forgotten he
showed up with no notes in front of him
which got me a little bit nervous that
he didn't have it in front of him that
he committed it to memory
and um so he was asked about xavian
howard he gave a serious response to it
and then
finished up with that
did he deal with that was there was it
was there and that was the walk-off it
was the walk-off it was the walk-off
answer was there eye contact maybe
between you and him that kind of
about two questions before it was asked
by someone who was directly in front of
me
um and i think that's perhaps where he
spied me for the first time
knowing that i was
honoring my end of the commitment that
if i was in indianapolis i would be
there
and i was
and then
he gave his answer
uh i was about three rows removed from
the
sort of i guess the the barrier is one
of those things like you know that you
have in an airport you know with the
where where
you have to lift yeah the retractable
kind of uh
lift yeah you had to lift that
quote-unquote belt
um i tried to do that
couldn't do it then i just went
underneath
went and high-fived him and thought like
you know it would be awkward if i stuck
around
um
he said boom as we high-fived which i
thought was a nice touch on his part
at which point um he then turned around
and told me he did all four of them
and he did say something about
controlling what you can control
um
about a couple of lines before he
finished up strong
so
guys he's a man of his word amazing did
it my dream has been fulfilled
and um
i don't know what else to do what what
was the response from from your your
peers there that you were around i mean
where are they confused uh ryan total
complete bewilderment yeah
yeah there was a woman that rich like
what where
yeah you could see some of the videos
that are out there they're they're
wondering what has just happened
why why is the guy from nfl network
screaming yes and high-fiving a coach at
the end of his press conference there
were a couple people there who were in
the know if they weren't in the know
the fact that nfl network uh t-man the
great mark titleman who was the producer
of our combine coverage saw
this interview the other day
i was mic'd up there was a camera on me
it's a production now guys it's called
content
creation
and um they're putting a little piece
together you're an influencer rich eisen
on this you know i i look look uh i i
just try to make dreams
come true
for myself
um and i've been talking about this
these coaching cliches for quite some
time
because coaches i don't know why they
would even assume that we thought they
had a crystal ball
um we all know that like they're wizards
or something
yes like everything in life anything in
any endeavor can be boiled down to
whatever we're talking about is what it
is
right i mean it's not just football it's
any endeavor in life this this
conversation is
what it is i hope it is entertaining and
even
slightly informative i mean but it is
what it is and then really the only
thing that we can control in our lives
is what we can control
and um
the fact that a coach prompted
with this information
used them all in the same sentence that
was his
raising of the stakes not mine or ours
it's great ryan i don't know what else
to say other than um it's a crowning
achievement day
and i'm glad that we can all share it
together i am too i i feel a part of
something you know and i rarely feel a
part of something so you've done another
another service for me all right so
thank you thank you very much hey
the honeymoon period for
for new coaches right it's it's a big
deal right i mean robert sala and what
that looked like a year ago you were you
know dan campbell and what it led up to
the season and then you know reality
season happened so the mike mcdaniel
honeymoon period has been
rather interesting and fun here for the
first month or so just an interesting
guy man and i mean before all that
somebody asked him
about finding
you know a debo samuel for his
offense right yeah and his answer was
yes uh i i intend
to get as many first-team all-pro
players as i possibly can get that was
his answer he goes i think it's
important for my coaching success
to have as many first-team all-pro
players as i possibly can get i mean
he's funny and he's whip smart and
obviously it's just all going to come
down to what happens in the crucible of
a game and game day and leaders leading
men in the locker room
and all sorts of stuff and
you know or how he'll handle it at some
point in time if you know the owner
decides to give him six figures to tank
like the previous coach that he did
i gotta tell you nobody brought that up
today and that's part of
why i think he's such an important hire
is because he's so fascinating in his
own right and so interesting in his own
way
and has such a unique way of talking
and communicating
and being so chill while being very
cerebral at the same time and also
seemingly in full command of
what he wants to execute and what he
needs
in terms of a roster and also in terms
of support to execute it
that it's just going to be fascinating
to watch certainly since he goes up
against belichick twice a year
and um and the team that we all think is
a team to beat potentially in the asc
coming
up this season with a generationally
brilliant quarterback
and josh allen so i i think he's clearly
in a unique spot here
and and you know the honeymoon should be
a fun ride
to say the least and it's interesting
enough the guy who was at the podium
next to him
who might have been mystified by my
presence in high fiving and booms and
all that stuff was pete carroll
talking at the same time about seattle
having no intention of trading russell
wilson is you've got a coach who's
towards the back if you will nine of his
career
and also what he plans to do with his
quarterback which is nothing
um and and you know
that's the backdrop to everything this
week as we watch the current prospects
and future stars of the game
you know perform or participate or
however you want to
describe it and whatever else is going
on behind the scenes with veteran
quarterbacks in that carousel that that
spins in one way or another once aaron
rodgers makes a decision right the the
quarterback conversation did was coach
mcdaniel asked a question around that
around you know what the mandate was
when it came to
he he said essentially that they're
looking for a quarterback a third one
because they only have two on the roster
and that no team he knows of has just
two quarterbacks and he said they're
going to find a veteran quarterback and
the best one that they could find that
was
that was his ques i mean there was no
question about tua being
his guy moving forward
and then the guy who took
that spot at the podium
next was howie roseman the uh grocery
shopper if you will or
executive in charge of the roster in
philadelphia
and he reiterated it's jalen hurts his
gig
and says jalen hurts the quarterback
somebody mentioned the name deshaun
watson to him his answer was jalen hurts
as our quarterback
that's different much different than
chris ballard and the hierarchy with
indianapolis a day ago no question well
there's no doubt about that but
the interesting thing about you know
whether the colts are going to stick
with wentz and what you know their moves
might be
uh i i would proper to say they were one
of those sleeper
teams for aaron rodgers i would think
um if rogers would be interested in
doing that you know and if he's
interested potentially in taking the
peyton manning way to finish his career
which is go to denver perhaps he takes
the peyton manning way to finish his
career the way that peyton started it
and come to this town
where there is a seemingly ready-made
team to win in a dome
in a conference that one would think you
know the packers would want to send them
to
um so that that that's a potential
backdrop to what chris ballard had to
say and a potential backdrop to what
howie roseman had to say is the man has
three first-round selections because
of the carson wentz trade that went down
um so
there's really you know a sense about
what things are
in terms of a snapshot right now and how
things can change in the next three
weeks because the new league year begins
three weeks from today right uh on the
on the 18th of march and
um
so
we'll see you know or 16th of march
pardon me so that's two weeks from today
actually
so it it's it's right around the corner
and decisions need to get made and plans
need to be uh pulled out of a drawer and
executed or pulled out of a drawer and
thrown away
and um
that's part of the fascinating backdrop
here
you know and tonight
is the first time i'm gonna drop myself
into the community of agents and
you know
uh
newsmakers and tastemakers and all that
stuff
and uh and put my ear to the ground and
see what i can
see what whispers i can pick up because
they're all over this town right now
before before we had you on we were in
in in serious uh conversations uh about
me becoming the thursday night amazon uh
color commentator and so your job
tonight is to uh put out that vibe okay
just put that vibe out
you just did it i mean i think you just
did it
you know um have you been on the bezos
rocket have you been on that i haven't
yet um i'm willing to i'm willing to fly
to space to do that job just putting
that out there that's about work ethic
here everybody work ethic okay
um okay tomorrow since tonight will be
your first opportunity to intermingle
and kind of get the nuance i i look
forward to hearing um some real inside
baseball tomorrow from your time tonight
with all those insiders
i will do it i will be back on the show
tomorrow and uh guys we did it yes we
did it today we did it really it's for
all of us right this is an
accomplishment right up there with being
drafted second overall rich it really is
i don't know i'm talking about you know
brockman and tj and those guys have been
around me knowing about my dream no it
is for me too this is what i this is how
i feel i'm just letting you know how
meaningful this was for me too rich i
actually wrote down in a notebook here
from december the 3rd 2020 when you
gave us those three traits and you
really were like i want a coach to say
it so i wrote it down to mark the
occasion then two years later less than
two years you made it happen
that's manifesting destiny everybody
that's what that is that's what it is
it's what when mike mcdaniel came on the
show the other day he talked about his
origin
2005 being a coaching intern for mike
shanahan
that day built up to today guys it's all
meant to be all meant to be rich i'm
just really glad that security didn't uh
tackle you as you broke through the
barricade like that uh heading towards
an nfl coach i broke several protocols
well done well done sir well done
honestly i mean just in terms of
professionalism
um you know shoving
members of the media out of the way
sort of like trump did to the poor
president of montenegro years ago you
remember that rolled right up to the
front
shoved people out of the way
went underneath a rope
jumped up in the middle of a press
conference pete carroll's to my right
john robinson of the titans to my left
and i just jumped right in there and
high-fived an nfl head coach because he
did something totally silly and i love
it today's a great day today is a great
day
rich eyes and everybody joining us from
indianapolis on the mercedes-benz vance
phone line thanks for having uh for
having me and thanks for being on the
show
no i'll speak to you tomorrow guys all
right all right rich
all right host of the rich eisen show
rich eisen joining us from indianapolis
could you imagine if security just ran
in like spiritual rich like goldberg
like
terry crews him or what is it
office linebacker just smoked him and
then everybody's just like oh yeah
that's what you get that's what you get
we're making a mockery of our press
conference here
if richmond got speared
like roman reigns just came out of the
crowd and blasted them that'd be amazing
and mike mcdaniel though he was a part
of it he may have some words with nfl
security when it's done like hey how did
you let that guy get so close to me yeah
how are you letting these these these
these crazies get so close to me right i
mean i'm trying to do a job here um and
he really he literally said boom at the
impact
appropriate response and inappropriate
behavior right there um by rich eisen
and mike grown men doing silly things
for themselves
and i think that's what keeps us all
young yeah you know doing silly things
of course you know childish things
haven't we been doing that for two plus
hours today
indeed we have
indeed
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here